vuelven a sonar las alarmas ante una
nueva variante de coronavirus fue
detectada por primera vez en sudáfrica y
aunque aún no tiene nombre oficial se le
conoce como la vez 11 529 parece ser la
más transmisible hasta el momento y no
ha tardado en propagarse el primer caso
en europa ya fue confirmado en bélgica
con firma de sudario
y tenemos un caso de esta variante que
ya está confirmado lo portaba una
persona que venía del extranjero y que
dio positivo el 22 de noviembre no
estaba vacunada y no se había contagiado
ante acción
la nueva variante presenta más de 30
mutaciones tendría una mayor
transmisibilidad y mayor capacidad para
sortear las defensas naturales y las de
las vacunas y llega a europa en un
momento de repunte de contagios de kobe
19 por lo que ha incrementado la
preocupación de la unión europea que ya
ha anunciado que cerrará sus fronteras
con el sur de áfrica
la comisión europea ha propuesto hoy a
los estados miembros que interrumpan
urgentemente los viajes desde los países
del sur de áfrica y otras naciones
afectadas para limitar la propagación de
la nueva variante solemne transfer of
the new berlin en áfrica junto a otros
países del mundo marruecos también
prohibió la entrada de viajeros
procedentes de sudáfrica y otras
naciones de la región sin embargo el ao
ms hizo un llamado a la calma el butt
sheikh weeks tardaremos unas semanas
para comprender el impacto de esta
variante
los investigadores están trabajando para
comprender mejor las mutaciones y lo que
significan potencialmente en cuanto a
transmisibilidad o virulencia y cómo
pueden afectar nuestros diagnósticos con
terapia y vacunas android things una
nueva ola de incertidumbre casi dos años
después del inicio de la pandemia